oh I forgot her name off the top of my
head oh Sydney Watson Sydney Watson and
I guess she's a big like YouTuber and
I've I've recognized her I'd seen her
before and she was on the panel with me
and there's this guy named Eli and I
didn't know any of this drama but I
guess Eli I thought this was an
accusation but I guess he publicly put
on his Instagram he's giving drugs to
minors two Miners and and I guess like
Blair White made there's all this
conservative drama that I've never heard
of and but I guess Blair White made a
video about him that he has like grape
accusations and um yeah and so we're
gonna talk about me too and I think he
said something about like believing
women or he she I don't know and she
goes that's funny that you say that with
all the accusations that are out against
you I didn't I was just sitting there
like